[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
what you just saw was only a glimpse of
the Assassin's Creed symphony tour
starting on June 29th imagine an 80
piece live orchestra and choir playing
the iconic themes from Assassin's Creed
while you relive some of the most
memorable moments from over a decade of
Assassin's Creed in an immersive
experience
check out AC Symphony comm to learn more
I mean excellent music great
performances goosebumps if you like
those things I think those shows are
gonna be for you but of course there's
one show that we all came here to see
the Ubisoft III conference and it's just
about to start here from the Orpheum
Theatre in Los Angeles now the house is
packed and to give you folks at home an
idea what that feels like can I please
hear the balcony people make some noise
now now if you if you please if you
please I'd like to do the same for the
people sitting on the ground floor
well the excitement is here folks we
hope you're feeling the same way there
from everyone at Ubisoft all around the
world please enjoy the show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
London greatest city in the world well
used to be there's a rightness
governments [ __ ] off extremists a grab
in power
organized crimes slicing up the boroughs
the war docks are outs and freedoms are
bloody joke but they say their London
this is our London and there's a new
power growing it's all of us together
we're building a resistance one recruit
at a time what's my favorite operative
up to this evening and though I never
say that to the others skirt and
challenge badly so gob shut eyes peeled
yes I have no lies and if I did I
wouldn't peel them
[Music]
Vladdy drives are everywhere kicking our
[ __ ] teeth in lately then I recommend
you recruit someone who can deal with
drones brilliant never would have
thought of that
you're clear sawed-off right easy
I'm complying hmm
impressive skill set sure but we need a
drone expert Raj not shitkicker file
that one away for later
are you concerned about the increased
Albion presence in London if the total
disgrace
come on well now Jimmy sure no formal
engineering training but he has several
mischief charges to hijacking Albion
drones Oh still find out drone expert
he's about to get himself
Wesley just ignore me
time
now to say
we'll chase drugs converging on your
position function
[Applause]
I need to tell me about my buddy
checkboard oh boy
[Applause]
[Music]
lost Ian he's gone
lovely evening isn't it ah I used to
feed the birds here now they're all
bloody machines get used to it in the
long march of progress everything dies
eventually eventually even you badly I'm
sure now there's my heaven speaking of
death you'll never guess what just
happened to Ian Oh for god sake badly a
little respect
there let's finish what he started he
was working on a new recruit a drone
expert that's promising what do we know
about him Albion stands Jimmy just
before he was killed
I should be able to predict his next
move from that beta unfortunately his
records are locked up tighter than your
compression stockings ah my Albion sivan
taken over Scotland Yard complicates
matters there's my way in hello darling
[Music]
time to go they'll be on to me
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
the files you stole indicate that
Jimmy's gone to Kanda market let's get
someone opened that badly top top ready
for some action they are they always the
biz recruit better be worth over trouble
according to the Scotland Yard records
Jimmy's sister was killed by plan Kelly
we believe he's seeking his revenge
inside camden market camden black market
you mean yes the Kelly's are rumors
about all sorts of illicit goods out of
the old stables
some with fingers and toes
if he's gone in there alone he's in big
trouble
Kelly's at this place on full lockdown
hmm I have an idea
today everything's all fine and dandy
[Music]
now Naomi we've already lost one
operative so try not to get killed or
we'll be in the red for the day
copy that
[Music]
this is Sammy this patio John Thompson
cannabis and fentanyl together at last
through the miracle of genetics
the Kelly's are moving loads of weapons
out here
not your typical back alley shanks
stables it's human trafficking found
Jimmy cheek [ __ ] and here we thought he
might be in some sort of trouble now
there lots of hugs and kisses
[Music]
[Music]
on your feet mate
oh wait a minute you get sick hope
you're sharper than you look
chase this Christ
baby's sake creeps
they're rolling help
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
or we showed those [ __ ] didn't we we
almost died out there tonight look
thanks for helping me but I can handle
myself right you think you're better off
alone you think everyone else has given
up and there's no one to trust that's
what they want you to think and that's
how they'll take us one at a time it
doesn't have to be that way together we
can change things wait what happened to
that bloke who helped me he didn't make
it
[ __ ] it welcome to dedsec James yeah
okay so where do I go to meet the rest
of the crew you don't need to go
anywhere
look around you everyone has a reason to
fight and dedsec is open to anyone
anyone
welcome to the resistance
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
thank you guess I'm going to make you
all wait so long I should really knock
it out of the park huh I'm Clint Hawking
I'm the creative director of watchdogs
Legion and for the past few years the
team and I have had the privilege to
work on a game and an innovation that we
are very proud of
watchdogs Legion is set in London one of
the greatest cities in the world
and it's had a massive influence on all
of our culture for centuries today with
brexit London's at a turning point it's
hard to predict what the future holds
for London for the UK or for the world
but history has proven time and again
that where London goes all of us go
together in our near future
London is facing her downfall the UK has
become a surveillance state and freedom
has been replaced with fear armed drones
patrol the streets deportation squads
rip people from their homes
and grandad is using crypto to buy a new
kidney on the black market
but Londoners never surrender their
resilience and determination is an
inspiration to us all and they are the
heroes of our game all of them in
watchdogs Legion your mission is to
build a popular resistance to fight back
against the emergence of an
authoritarian regime this means you
don't just play as one hero but many and
in watchdog's legion you can recruit and
play as anyone
in our game every Londoner is fully
simulated with a persistent life and
relationships and anyone from the entire
population can be recruited into your
team find them profile them hack into
their lives play their origin mission
and win them over to your cause the
heroes you recruit are all unique
characters with different backstories
and personalities fully voiced and
animated and they are the stars of your
story every cinematic in the game will
change depending on whether you're
playing a former mi5 action hero a 70
year old granny a soft feeding pigeons
in the park or anyone in between however
you want to play whoever you want to be
watchdogs legion lets you be that you
want to make a team of classic British
spies no problem you want to be a crew
of street savvy kids from the council
block do it you want to go hipster
body-mod afropunk gangsta awesome
the women of Bletchley Park these ladies
[ __ ] invented hacking
play as anyone is the innovation that
transforms a story about freeing London
in the world from the grip of tyranny
into a game about the heroes that live
in each of us because being a hero isn't
just a job for someone else anymore it's
a job for everyone so on behalf of the
watchdog's legions team here and around
the world I hope to see you on the booth
thank you for your time and welcome to
the resistance
[Applause]
London had a good run there for a while
now it's alright
bombings
and people thrown in cages like animals
oh hello you can forget the killer
robots everywhere
so yeah let's knock on a bit [ __ ] it's
up to us to take our city back there is
if we can't do it alone we need to
recruit a resistance
I know what you're thinking where do we
start open your eyes and take a look
around okay look it in now not him him
form an mi5 beauty never ends they can
get anywhere in a race anyone got kicked
out of Oxford for a bollocks school for
teaching him to reproduce
[Music]
and I fell over there
proper Belen come on drama me LLL crack
your skull just to look at that funny
[Music]
ha
this had better be [ __ ] good and
allow me to introduce you to the
deadliest of the love was his not old
she's experienced like I said you can
recruit anyone and all me bloody anyone
him/her everyone is a secret weapon
find them recruit them build the
resistance
[Music]
let's unfuck this world
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well my name is Rob McElhenney and for
the past fourteen years I have been
making a television show called It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia thank you
but I am here today because I love games
and I wanted to express that love and
the only way that I know how save for
playing them and that is to make a TV
show about them more importantly the
people who create those games and the
people who play them so last year I
called the funniest people that I knew
Charlie Day Megan Gans and David Hornsby
all executive producers on sunny and we
started talking we realized very early
on that if we were going to do this we
wanted to do it right and to be as
authentic as possible because as you all
know nobody smells [ __ ] like this
particular community so we did the right
thing we partnered with Ubisoft and away
we went
it has been an incredible experience
working with one of the biggest and best
game developers in the world to inspire
us because our show takes place in the
fictional studio that created the
biggest MMORPG in the world mythic quest
and we meet them on the cusp of
releasing their biggest expansion yet
mythic quest Ravens banquet the show
follows the team of devs as they
navigate the challenges of running their
game while dealing with the difficulties
of modern office life these people are
truly stuck together yet they grind it
out day after day for the love of the
game and at the head of that team is my
character creative director ayan grim
like
[Laughter]
like most creative directors he's gifted
driven and tirelessly dedicated to his
game and like most of the creative
directors that I've met he has an ego
the size of a city bus I'm gonna get my
ass kicked backstage because there's a
lot of creative reppin here joking aside
it is clear that those creative
directors and the thousands of people
who work on these games put everything
that they can into them they recognize
that they have a tremendous opportunity
and responsibility that they must do
everything in their power to ensure that
the games are nothing short of the best
that they can make because that is what
the community you deserve I promise you
that in making this show we took the
same approach so without further ado
here is a brief look into our upcoming
TV series for Apple TV plus mythic quest
Ravens banquet
[Applause]
what is Miffy quest some may say it's
just a video game
[Music]
when it first debuted MQ was hailed as a
masterpiece now played in 20 different
countries on six continents
it's the biggest massive multiplayer
role-playing game of all time
[Music]
and today they find themselves on the
precipice of their first major expansion
Qwest Ravens banquet and it all falls on
the shoulders of one man creative
director
ayan grim when we think about cultural
touchstones we think ET star wars avatar
and yet our industry Dwarfs the
traditional entertainment business so
when we think about legends why not
think significance true indeed and when
we think of visionary world-building
artists instead of just Spielberg Lucas
and Cameron why not sink
[Music]
I'm sorry I gotta stop what is this it's
a commercial for the game it's a
commercial for you it's still going
my god this is insane
I think it's brilliant
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey there my name is Parker and taro
Makai a sportscaster for Rainbow six
siege there are so many exciting things
to come in year 4 in-game events map
reworks playlists updates a roster of 52
unique operators and of course a
thriving eSports scene starting tomorrow
you'll be able to enjoy our 13th season
operation phantom site this major
content update brings two new operators
to team rainbow nuke and warden after
this show be sure to stick around for an
intense celebrity match starring t-pain
little yachty and some of your favorite
twitch streamers for the twitch rivals
celebrity show match but right now
here's a glimpse of the new season in
action thank you everyone and have a
great a three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
again that's what you get when you take
on the brawlhalla master what if he won
me bro for real
yeah I'll toast your buns again sure
want to choose a different character
yeah I choose
[Music]
my burrito whoa this those guys from the
game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
says everything
[Music]
forty-five million players
dude that's almost 25 million making
pancakes makin bacon pancakes bah wah
wah-wah-wah-wah
no man
this game is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the only test a man's worth its battle
those rounds come screaming past your
head you're gonna learn if you're hungry
enough hungry enough to take that
victory
we're gonna battle with the soldiers
that we used to be ghosts and you better
believe that they are hungry too once
upon a time some of these ghosts they
may have been your friends and there is
brotherhood but then there is what the
world needs these ghosts they are the
past they still serve the Machine that
we left behind right now for the future
the world needs us
[Music]
I'm honored I'm honored to be here with
you tonight
and as you head in the battle with that
mean look in your eye those bad
intentions in your mind remember this
you are the few with the courage to make
history
you had the desire to take victory you
will be on a battlefield full of ghosts
but only you
that makes you lose
[Music]
probably what's going on everybody
hey I'm John good to be here this is
bambam the dog thank you thank you it's
a real honor to be here with you guys
today thank you I love you too right on
this is awesome this has been really
great and exciting and I'm really I'm
really honored to be here I'm I'm
enormous ly proud to be part of the
development of this game
it was a pleasure to work with the
Ubisoft team you know I've had the
chance to play some pretty strong tough
men over the years I've played a deputy
fighting zombies special Special Forces
soldier who lost everything and now I
get to play a coldie Walker he's a
skilled former Special Operations
soldier with his own sense of
responsibility his own moral code
he knows how things should be run he
loves his brothers his fellow soldiers
but he is willing to do whatever it
takes to complete his mission and take
control of aroa
there is no briefing there's no backup
you will not face a group of bad guys or
criminal organization you will face an
entire army my army the wolves
we got the numbers we've got the
organization and remember we trained
alongside you the weaponry of a fully
operational special ops detachment trust
me there's an unparalleled arsenal of
high-tech weapons in ER OA so if you
think you have what it takes
strap on your boots and you get ready to
take on the Wolves take on me see you in
a row we'll be waiting
or perfect predators they have the
knowledge of their hunting ground but we
have the element of surprise
they have the technology but we have the
skills to even the odds
they ever know
we fight with our brothers and sisters
[Music]
they are hungry but we are enraged
[Music]
we are ghosts
and ghosts never die
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi everyone being a community developer
on Ghost Recon wildlands and breakpoint
has been an incredible journey for me so
far when we first announced the game you
were very excited and after discussions
of members of our community I today
announced that with our post launch plan
we will be bringing back our AI
teammates for solo player
[Applause]
with Ghost Recon breakpoint we want to
go the extra mile with how we engage
with you so I'm pleased to announce a
brand new community program that will
allow you to express and share your
passion welcome to Ghost Recon Delta
company
from cosplay to streaming fanarts of
forum discussions however you show your
love for Ghost Recon there is something
for you in our five different
detachments with lots of content to
support you as well as direct
discussions with our studio so head over
to our Ghost Recon great print website
to find out more and hear from you soon
Delta ghosts thank you very much
everyone
[Applause]
[Music]
Thank You Lora hello everyone the ghost
recon team has always taken great pride
from your passion for our games and that
passion is what pushes us to deliver the
best SpecOps experience out there behind
enemy lines you will be fighting the
most dangerous enemies the ghosts have
ever faced constantly testing your
survival skills yes we can't wait to
welcome you in Ghost Recon blood point
on October 4th and one more before that
our beta will be live on September 5th
you can register on our website right
now for chance to participate Ghost
Recon breakpoint will be live for years
to come
we've got your back
new content free updates and many
surprises inspired by our community yes
yes like this one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
will you survive your break point
[Music]
alright see you all out there have a
good one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Megan a dauntless and daring agent she's
all in all out
always montane counterterrorism and
rescue veteran his best offense this is
defense
nomads covert special ops team leader a
ghost on the battlefield
guevara highly-skilled defending
operator lightly-armed massively
effective
Sam Fisher delete covert operative the
lone wolf now hunts with a pack
when chaos strikes
rally to specialists
leave the elite squad
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
pre-register now
[Applause]
[Music]
ten years ten years that's a lot of
dancing we're exhausted I know but think
of everything we've done it's not for us
or for you or you it's for them the
players we danced and Sileo and his
girlfriend got married we danced and our
friend Jaden Rodriguez danced for
millions bringing together generations
we danced and they set world records
do you remember Carrie yes of course we
do because we were with her tonight
yes dance is why we exist and I know
we're gonna have much more these moments
because dance is a force it's
transcendent it unites and it shows us
who we are that's why just that it's
more than just dance
[Applause]
and get ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's an old tale about this village a
samurai came to deliver justice
but darkness clouded our minds she
slaughtered every living soul
and became the spirits of death
years later we hunted the samurai in the
village we didn't believe the old pail
knocked on tears came
we're its honker for our sores
[Music]
be wary Sequoia is the spirit of death
and she's brought a curse that with
Duman are saw
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we found him thank you
I'll cover you
to the point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm Bo shad another lead game
designer on the next Rainbow six game
it's called Tom Clancy's Rainbow six
quarantine I'm part of a new team in
Ubisoft Montreal that set out on an
exciting new mission create a radically
redesign co-op experience built on the
foundations of one of the best shooters
of this generation what siege is to the
PvP shooter genre we will be - PvE co-op
quarantine will test your tactical
skills and survival instincts holding
you and your operators on the razor's
edge it pulls you together as a squad
facing off against an unknown and
devastating parasite you will risk
everything every time you step into
quarantine stay tuned and start prepping
for your next deployment I can't wait to
show you more and have a great eatery
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm as creative director at Red Storm
entertainment there's no greater reward
for me or the team than to see our game
come to life and to see our players our
star players taking tremendous pride in
being a part of the division yeah now if
you haven't had the opportunity to play
the division 2 yet we would be thrilled
to have you join our very passionate
community because I'm happy to announce
that this week only between June 13th
and June 16th the division 2 will be
absolutely 100% free for everyone to
play and there's no better time to join
us as we were about to release the first
of our major content updates for a year
one journey a journey beyond Washington
DC to save not just a city but an entire
nation
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right thank you
episode 1 coming in July right around
the corner we delivered to you new main
missions and a brand new game experience
so for the first time we're taking the
fight outside the city and you'll
venture deep into the woodlands to
spearhead an attack on a presidential
compound as you seek to bring a traitor
to justice the National Zoo is the
setting of our next mission where you
and your team will hunt down the
surviving outcasts leader and this
brings us to our final edition of
episode 1 a place called Kenley College
and it's home to an entirely new
gameplay experience one that will take
exploration investigation and logic to
uncover the fate of a military convoy
gone dark now episode 2 coming this fall
we will bring to you the Pentagon once
an impenetrable fortress it has fallen
to the black tusks and its secrets are
about to be thrown out into the open you
must do everything it takes to secure
what lies behind the walls of this last
castle but this won't be the greatest
danger you face in episode 2 I'm very
excited to tell you that our second raid
will be coming this fall bringing back
intense 8-player action
what you tackle the first raid that was
awesome and we cannot wait to see what
world records you break this time around
now this brings us to our third and
final episode of year one what-if
rebirth was not about bringing in the
world as we know it back to life but the
opposite one man holds that power and
humanity itself is at stake agents it's
time to engage in a manhunt
[Music]
in this chart
[Applause]
we had the training
[Music]
we fought to protect the weak
but training doesn't prepare you to on
someone you used to call brother
he has left us no other choice if we
don't stop him
there will be nothing left to save
holy [ __ ] what about that I can't wait
for that okay one last thing as you
might know we have been working on a
movie it will be directed by david
leitch starring Jessica Chastain and
Jake Gyllenhaal well today I'm proud to
announce that we will be making the
division movie with Netflix more to come
on that in the future thank you very
much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow hello everyone I'm Brenda Penner
grossie I'm vice president of platform
and product management Ubisoft has been
creating worlds for over 30 years we
have the most diverse library of games
and we're about to make it even easier
for you to play them I'm here to
announce Ubisoft's news subscription
service on PC called you play plus
you'll get earliest available access to
new games including the premium editions
with all their additional content and
you can enjoy the depth of our PC
catalog that includes over 100 games and
growing
you play plus will be $14.99 a month if
you sign up today will enable free
access for you in September at launch
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
for great lachemann
for greatness man
this man
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for greatness man
[Music]
wherever players are we want to provide
access to our games and services I'm
pleased to announce that in 2020 you
play Plus will be available on stadia
[Music]
stadia is the new generation gaming
platform or you could play our stadia
games from any device a special thank
you to Phil Harrison and his team this
is beginning of our partnership
thank you so much have fun playing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hello future champions my name is Stefan
and I'm a proud member of the roller
champions team all right come on bring
it up from the get-go our ambitions with
this game were very clear we wanted to
create something new we wanted to
capture the intangible excitement of
players preparing for the big game the
hype of team play and competition along
with the craziness of high speed racing
so we started working on roller
champions a skill-based team pvp sports
game that is as fun to watch as it is to
play a game in which you the player can
create your own story as you roll up to
glory but right now I know how it looks
we showed you a trailer and I got on
stage starting my little speech that's
all well and good but when will you ever
get to play this how about today
that's right when we're done here I want
you to head over to you play on your PC
to download a pre-alpha III demo of
roller champions play the heck out of it
for the next few days and when you're
done head to the forums to tell us what
you thought and you know what we firmly
believe that you will be screaming as
loudly as our colleagues did when they
first got to play tested back in
Montreal but I can't just leave you with
that so here's a taste of what you
should expect once you click that
download button put your skates on see
you in the arena
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so first I want to say thank you to
thank you so first I want to say thank
you to all the Ubisoft teams around the
world for your talent and energy you
know congratulations for another great
show
so I believe video games have a positive
impact on all of us and the world around
us and Ubisoft our intention is to
create game that will make you stronger
and appear in your life when you play
with soft games we hope you will spend
quality time with family and friends and
meet new inspiring people learn more
about yourself by doing and gain new
perspective on the world and help shape
it so to everyone who play our games
thank you for your love
[Music]
you can chance you always do better and
go further so now I'm very proud to
announce a new project from an
exceptional team in Quebec City please
give a warm upload to back ELISA Cote
who is coming to show you a sneak peek
of its game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you hello everybody over the last
10 years I've had the chance to be part
of an incredible team that has always
pushed the limits of Assassin's Creed
and shown us different periods of our
past but our imagination has always been
bound to the reality of the history
books these past four years our minds
have lingered on a different aspect of
our history mythology the stories of the
ancient gods and their misadventures
have existed through generations of
storytellers and audiences and I've
transformed into tales that we still
know and love today
now these stories have shaped our dreams
inspiring us to build something new
something that transcends the limits
that we have always set upon ourselves
today I am very proud to have the chance
to show you a glimpse to show you a
teaser of this brand-new game that we've
been working on I hope you enjoy it
thank you and have a great a three
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
when heroes need help they turn to the
gods
[Music]
regards detail
they turn to you
[Music]
here we are
hello everybody let me thicken let me
think it in me
hello everybody at home thank you so
much for watching
I hope you had a great show but this is
just the beginning guys this is just the
beginning thank you thank you thank you
this is just the beginning we are here
outside of the Orpheum Theater live from
the Pro zone where we have an incredible
rainbow fix each show match together
with twitch rival we have our two new
best friends t-pain hello everyone
welcome back to game spots III 2019
coverage we just watched Ubisoft's
presser if you were not here before the
show i'll judice you to Michael hi I'm
hi
Lucy James hey Kelly Blackie and I'm
Mike McCarty let's dive into what we
just saw some surprises some things we
expected largely due to leaks kind of
Ubisoft a rhythm in general all right
start watchdogs Legion I'm super
impressed by that No so we based on the
leaks everything we knew that you could
play as anyone Clint Hocking creative
director of far cry 2 and then a
Splinter Cell came on he was directing
watchdogs Legion which is great because
he hasn't really made anything in a long
time or released anything in a long time
I don't know this looks really cool
ambitious is the word I've used to
describe it hopefully that eventually
comes to fruition
Michael what did the press conference
make you think watchdogs Legion they are
getting political it's a they're really
going heavy on the the idea of
revolution and rebellion yeah in this so
my first thing I'm looking out for how
this is going to account for a post
brexit world or whatever how they're
gonna play